is
[Music]
good rancher
here you go dandelion and mordecai
all right
if you eat all your seed i'll sing you
your song
oh boy
eat all your seed
that's why i put the xylophone here
eat all your seed i love chickens eat
all your seed cluck [ __ ] [ __ ]
bad rancher
where are my eggs
[Music]
don't look at me like that i told you i
wanna
[Music]
get it
go with the good ranchers 100
american-sourced steakhouse quality
means subscribe today at
goodranchers.com
lock in your 25 off every box for the
entire life of your subscription
good ranchers american meat delivered
june 18th pikes peak center colorado
springs colorado prepares
for the funniest
show
on
earth moving right along
put loose and fancy free
getting there is half the fun compare it
with me
moving right along
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
oh boy that is a delicious oh am i am i
getting a little room noise or is that
just me in my headphones
uh i think that's is it just me and my
headphones all right that's just me and
my headphones good uh could you know
what it was we were recording that music
here the other day
in this room and so i had to change the
levels and i uh i won't be able to hear
right for a week glad to be with you
sorry we're a little late uh some
technical uh difficulties that happened
with uh uh let's just blame it on
twitter there yeah we'll blow it on
twitter for today uh and that is going
to be look first off uh well we have
gerald b in studio you guys see this
because he's uh
he's uh oh yeah gerald a is having uh
his his wife is with child and uh i
don't know if you know that but jlb does
a great impression of a lamprey you see
that guy
it's just that that's his catchphrase
yeah i think that soundboard might be
coming in a little bit hot i don't know
if it's just me it could be my
headphones acting up but sorry it's just
it's distracting me
it might be the headphones it could just
be the headphones let's hear it again
and i'll check guys i'm gay oh no that
sounds about right that's good yeah
spot on
so we're going to be talking today not
just about twitter uh we're going to
talk about the the ministry of truth
that this administration is is
incorporating right now that they're
putting into action which is absolutely
terrifying
and uh with twitter people have been
talking about how they've been gaining
followers right or i've been losing
followers but once you get past the sort
of uh
histrionics
um the ostentatious just ah
what does it really mean we've run some
numbers not just for personalities but
specifically politicians
which politicians have gained followers
what they've gained which politicians
have have lost followers what they've
lost and what kind of a direct impact
that could have
on what what the election turns out
doesn't really matter if russia spends
six thousand dollars on facebook ads
turns out that twitter itself and of
course by proxy facebook instagram
youtube can have a direct impact on an
election and we're not just talking
about the new york post story uh
we're talking about every single
election from local state all the way up
to federal
and it is shocking it's startling so
this is good this is good what we're
seeing it's
we're gaining some ground but uh
it's not enough also uh we're going to
enter a recession that's something that
a lot of people aren't talking about
because it's nerdy it's tough to get
into but we're going to try and
consolidate it so you can understand why
historically the metrics that we are
seeing
have never resulted in anything other
than a woeful recession so let me ask
you this before while we're talking
about the ministry of truth and we'll be
talking about twitter my question of the
day to you is
and will pin the comment uh who whoever
answers best
which lie is the worst that we've had
from this administration at this point
the worst one not the one that bothers
you the worst one the most egregious uh
you know him you love him you have
gerald b back here mr lamprey look at
that
he's gorgeous
and then uh we still of course having
third chair uh you know we have him at
landau dave on the twitter and he's
going to be in green bay wisconsin this
saturday and then uh the meyer theater
and then of course we're in colorado
springs uh in june a lot of gutter.com
you can book your tickets how are you
dave ahoy i'm good and lincoln nebraska
i think next weekend and oh yeah ahoy
good just lay off i just wanted to share
that's enough it's a lincoln
like abe yeah i know or the car yeah
that's fine too honest dave i couldn't
do the old i couldn't do the oldsmobile
theater he's not there yet lincoln logs
they'll never hey watch it or we'll
never let you perform at pontiac i bet
there was an oldsmobile theater oh i
guarantee you i would like to go there
it's just a theater that nobody knows
exists anymore but it's still there the
seats are all just plush maroon yes
just velvet
you're your dad's smoking up front i'm
like i thought you were dead not in this
theater not in this not in the old
mobile things we're all ghosts
you matter it's almost like you're the
ghost because you're the only one who's
not it's i'm a reverse ghost oh the
front sections the cutlass sierra
so uh before that we also by the way the
pandemic is over we'll get to that in a
second according to dr fauci um first
this is we confirm this is real right we
confirm this is real we're sure this is
real i watched this and i thought well
this must be a parody and that's how you
know the left is beyond parody when it
took us about 30 minutes to do some
research that means looking through this
guy's linkedin looking through his
facebook looking through his tick tock
going is this an actual thing
turns out it is
and uh he wants to apologize for the way
white people look
why people don't make no sense
i'm here trying to
gear myself up
and you know hot myself up to go up into
work that seems fake i thought i put on
something it's nice this is my morphe
one tastes like sour babies good for his
dad i'm sitting here rubbing my lips
together and i'm like well she
i hardly got no lips you ever seen the
latina in her 50s look like she's in her
30s because i know for a damn fact
you're seeing a white woman
and her 30s look like she's seen in her
20s look like she's 50.
folks hit 30 and they lose their damn
chins
just just up and lose them
really anywhere from 20 to 50. i mean i
ain't trying to make nobody mad but
i mean [ __ ]
a lot of us out here looking like bony
ass meat sex to me it's just you
who decided we were the elite
on behalf of white folks i want to
apologize to everyone because we must be
a diluted bunch because we done
convinced ourselves a whole ass lie
he sounds like zecko fanaticus doing the
effeminate really don't make no sense to
me
i'm over here feeling ugly yeah in a wet
bandits took yeah it just
man i just all i'm saying is when the
neighbors moved in my property value
dropped i ain't trying to say nothing
wrong who said that we are the elite and
then he goes on behalf of white people
trying to insinuate he's a part of the
elite like he's he's a hipster seal team
yeah look look
no one is saying that you are elite now
insert any other race with what he just
said white people look like bony ass
bags of meat black women look like
big-ass bags of meat can't say that no
it would be awful
look i'm just trying to look normal i'm
putting on lipstick i'm painting my
nails my nails black i got a dangly
cross ring i got this hat that looks
like i'm in life aquatic with steve sisu
yeah what's going on here and i will say
this having twins this really i was just
talking uh with with pop's crowd about
this yesterday
and you you have a son but i have you
know young boy young girl okay yeah i am
a twin and i i love them both dearly but
you're a twin brother so with one boy
one girl i said look i am going to
there's always going to have to be some
untraining some sort of deconditioning
right from society especially if you
understand the world we live in
with my and there needs to be balance
for both of them
but with my daughter i know that i'm
going to have to correct the record that
says
you are beautiful you are perfect just
the way no matter what it is if she's
anorexic skinny you're beautiful you're
perfect if she's overweight blood type
putting you're beautiful you're perfect
if she works you're beautiful you're
perfect if she doesn't work you're
beautiful you're perfect that's what
that's what the message is and i know
that i'm going to have to decondition
my son
from being bombarded as a piece of [ __ ]
for something he has no control over
because he's a white male no one is
going to be telling my young white male
boy that he's fantastic you're great
just the way you are it's the only
subgroup of people
whom you actively tell they need to
change something about themselves which
is immutable now of course i want my
daughter to find her self-esteem and her
values and her accomplishments how she
treats people
but no one is perfect no one is
beautiful and perfect the way they are
and no one's a piece of crap
just because of how they were born and
it really is something that i think
about a lot and that guy just echoed it
in a deeply disturbing way yeah and if
anybody's telling your white kid that
they're beautiful and perfect just be
like look the the stranger has candy and
don't get in the van right that's the
only person who's interested yeah
exactly they really don't like white
young men it sucks to say i mean because
there's so many people that get mad when
you say that right but it's true like
this guy is just going on there to tell
you that white people are garbage i know
and he's white
why yeah well this is why you have you
know older boomers we talked about these
statistics the other day all the
references are available at
lydiacredit.com they were more racist
then you had a dip with generation x and
older millennials our generation
they were the least racist and then you
had it go up again with younger
millennials and zoomers why did did we
all of a sudden become more racist
no what happened is there was a divide
and conquer on the left said we need to
reawaken
we need to re-fan the flames the fire of
racism in order to gain votes that's
what happened and that's what you're
seeing here when we grew up we didn't
even think about it for the biggest
shows from the cosby show to fresh
prince to
family matters that you'd have family
matters you'd have right next to patrick
duffy on step by step that's the that's
the white and black cookie well no it's
because young guys who are white come up
let's say you're white you see that guy
yeah well you hate him and you hate the
people that he's siding with right and
then the black and people hate him too
yes yeah so it's pretty much his fault
it should be unifying yeah that guy yeah
everybody should hate that guy yes
exactly there you go common ground
and if you're not in a band stop
painting your nails you're a cashier yes
stop it sir
so here's something else a little more
policy focused but this is hey this is
great this is good news and we need to
celebrate good news that's been the
theme of this week uh on april 26th so a
couple of days ago
and we didn't have time to talk about it
because we didn't ash wednesday
yesterday uh uh anthony fauci the
science
yes declared on air that america is
officially out of the pandemic what
dr fauci let me broaden this out and ask
you
here we are it's the end of april it's
the spring of 2022. how close are we to
the end of this pandemic well that's an
unanswerable question for the following
reason and and i don't want to be
evasive about it but let me tell you why
i'm giving you that answer judy we are
certainly right now in this country out
of the pandemic phase there it is
[Music]
um
hey stephen uh we still have another
clip huh we still have another clip i
think uh saki followed this up
so there's no question that we're in a
moment a different moment in our fight
against kovid but we also know covet
isn't over and the pandemic isn't over
[Music]
sorry dude well [ __ ] rain on the parade
yeah
i just don't know anymore
i thought he was the science
he was is she the science is she misses
science she's the new scientist oh gosh
well and then we're losing the science
to msnbc now msnbc is going to have a
corner on the science that's just not
fair it's cause with her skin she can't
get any vitamin d in it no it's not
natural it's not possible she'll just
burn yeah also a vampire yeah she she
can't and she can't do her makeup
because if she looks in the mirror she
doesn't see anything if you open one
blind during that press conference yeah
she does she lights ablaze
so here's uh something else by the way
uh the minister well people are calling
it this but
this is something that i was talking
about before we get to twitter
uh
i i said this other day don't just look
at the story
look at the people who are telling the
story or the people who are defending
the story or the people on the opposing
side of the political spectrum you know
where you find yourself and how are they
defending it or try and observe their
self-awareness to me
what's concerning about this
is this next story is that no one at
this administration
just said oh wait no that's bad that's
going to look bad we want to do it we
just don't tell people that we do it
right it's sort of like athletes like
well we want to cheat we just we just
lie because we know that it's
yeah reflects poorly upon us and people
know that we cheat why we buy urine
exactly that's clean or in the case of
the russian olympic team it's the
government just supplies urine of course
so
and steroids yes
uh homeland security uh the secretary uh
alejandro mayorkas announced yesterday
evil just jeff bezos yes evil jeff
evil or jeff bezos
i didn't know that was possible maybe
slightly less evil jeff
so and this just happens to be
coinciding with twitter being purchased
by elon musk which we'll get to in a
second and the changes therein uh
majorca has just announced the creation
of the official misinformation this is
the government so i don't want to hear
it's a private company anymore because
this
entity that is being created by your
government
its sole purpose is designed to get its
tentacles into private companies the
misinformation governance board let's
hear may orcas describe it our under
secretary uh for policy rob silvers is
co-chair uh with our principal deputy
general counsel jennifer gaskell in um
leading a just recently constituted
misinformation disinformation governance
board so we're bringing uh the goal is
to bring
the department together to address this
threat i just read a very interesting
study that underscores the importance of
the the point that you make uh the
spread of myths and disinformation in
minority communities specifically and
we've got to get that
on that in the context of our cp3 and
other efforts now again
the government saying we're going to
create a board and if you you can go and
check the references whose purpose is
primarily designed to pressure social
media companies into doing their bidding
for example things like not allowing
information out there you know like the
wuhan lab leak theory or the hunter
biden story or uh the cdc death rates
for which we were suspended on youtube
right the cdc actual death rates just
flew versus kovid for children right the
this is misinformation or um reports on
a violation of pennsylvania's own high
court right regarding mail-in elections
this kind of misinformation
again this wouldn't be as concerning
if they weren't wrong all the time and
even have admitted to okay we got that
one wrong it's still pretty concerning
because anytime the government says
we're going to determine what
information is permissible or
impermissible um you've now given up
your freedom of speech across all
platforms you can't say it's a you can't
say it's a private company anymore if
the government gets to tell private
companies what is considered permissible
under the guise of misinformation and by
the way the person that he names who's
heading this up
nina yankowitz she's a global fellow at
the
non-partisan wilson center good thing
that it's non-partisan let me read you a
couple of this broads tweets
she said after elon musk purchased
twitter i shudder to think about if free
speech absolutists were taking over more
platforms
she also called the hunter biden laptop
a quote trump campaign product very
middle of the road yes a trump campaign
product that is proactive misinformation
think about this that was from the new
york post
and no one denied its authenticity right
aside from social media platforms no one
else in the press really no one else in
the actual press like new york times
they didn't say this isn't a true story
they just didn't like the story this
person who is now going to determine
what shows up or at least they're going
to attempt to i think elon musk is
probably going to put up some walls
uh
said it was just a campaign product for
donald trump that is proactively trying
to subvert democracy what the left
accuses you of doing they do themselves
it really is it's the olinsky 101 andrew
breitbart talked about that
just like you're seeing with amber hurd
and johnny depp she would accuse him of
a borderline personality disorder when
the shrink's like no you
who pooped in the bed emperor yeah so
let me uh yeah yeah who pooped in the
bed
what it was a prank it was a prank after
you left him and his mother was dying
don't you do that what how do you
comfort your spouse his mom was dying so
i pooped in his bed oh i forgot you
never made a mistake
so i'm only human yeah
barely i mean not really not a few i
mean i don't have a soul no i mean
sugar water i need sugar water so uh
this is a democrat activist now who is
at the head of this board and uh just to
give you some examples the
misinformation governance board if only
we would have some historical precedent
oh that's right we do of government
boards determining what information is
allowable
used to mainly apply to the press but of
course now you are the press
this is what this whole fight is about
with twitter right now you are the press
that's why the government needs to step
in they used to be able to send some
marching orders to just a handful of
outlets right all the news that's fit to
print three networks
now you're the press now you have a
camera
now you can do your own digging like us
and so they have to make sure they
create a government board to shut it
down because we can't have you being the
press but once upon a time we did have
these kinds of boards that existed to
specifically send marching orders to the
press we had the reich ministry of
public enlightenment and propaganda
if they do it my general rule is go
another direction but that's just one
way
there was uh there's the publicity
department at the uh central committee
uh central uh committee for the
communist chinese party there's north
korea's propaganda and agitation
department and of course uh there's the
fictional 1984 orwell's ministry of
truth which again does this exact thing
there's no self-awareness for them to
just say hey you know what hold on a
second if we're doing something that
orwell
fictitiously described as a dystopian
future what do you mean non-fiction yes
exactly what you mean yes yes i mean it
became that way he may have written it
as fiction yeah spot-on they're gonna
have to re-categorize it at the airport
right next to the white guilt checklist
book and the dvd of idiocracy yes
and we actually do have some uh oh if
i'm not mistaken um okay right now right
right now on cnn they're uh an
interaction with the misinformation
board and uh
someone with an infraction
[Music]
this is a cnn plus special report
[Applause]
yes
nothing
that's right
because you know
deep down
you deserve to be punished
[Music]
yeah that was i guess that was cnn plus
oh oh is that what that was yeah they
have some weird licensing agreements oh
i thought it was an old elliot page
movie yeah i don't necessarily guys i'm
gay
come on gerald that's out of line now
that's not a lot of his work gerald b
still doing the lamprey though it's
uncanny it really it really is yeah it
really is i like uh i like his teeth
better yeah yeah yeah
well you know none of them were shot out
with a bb gun no that's true not a one
yeah also around the office gets more
use out of it with a choice us yeah no
we have fun with it yeah well we need to
we have disinfectant around here so look
smash the like button really quickly
because we're going to get some
algorithm information here on twitter uh
youtube hitting like
commenting helps sharing we're now
seeing is the most important if you
share it on youtube and i hate to be
that guy who asks you to do those things
but i want to be able to get through
this information on twitter uh without
having to kind of break it apart we got
a new share button oh do we yeah what is
it
let me see click i can't see it yet
i don't know i kind of like this the
care bear thing yeah he was gay but i
was okay with it what happened guys i'm
gay that's way too loud going through
the board it's louder than anybody else
you got to take the volume down on him
being gay i mean i guess he's emphatic
about his gayness and we're proud of him
for that yeah
no we are i mean yeah yeah no it takes
yeah it does it takes balls especially
when you know he's i mean he's in the
hospital with his beard having another
child yes
it's hard to live a double life like
gerald no it is and it's nice that he
sent that is you know his his stunt
double yeah no it is yeah and by the way
we do pay scale so yeah oh absolutely
twitter this has been happening right
elon musk keep in mind
elon musk isn't at the helm at twitter
right now
so this is also some context that you
need to keep in mind uh
whatever changes you're seeing at
twitter
okay a lot of you are going oh elon
bought twitter and there's this hero
worship of him and i'm really glad that
he purchased twitter but what you are
seeing is self-inflicted it's people
running around with their heads cut off
the board going oh my god this is going
oh my god hold on a second people are
gonna find out so if you're seeing these
numbers change by the millions by the
way that's twitter's own people it's
their own staff right now
trying to cover their ass 100
so let's keep that in context and then i
want to get to some numbers that um
that not only are surprising uh
but their direct impact and there are
studies on this uh as to how it could
affect the outcome of elections we're
not even talking about the freest and
fairest election as far as the actual
mail-in votes or if miller voter fraud
has ever occurred ever you could type
voter fraud in at lotus crowder.com for
all those references but we would never
discuss it here of course we'll do it on
mug club later yeah uh where we do chat
thursday but all right
you know this republican accounts
particularly conservative accounts okay
but i wanted to focus on republican and
democrats today because i wanted to
focus on elected officials and then give
you some personal examples so uh
republican twitter accounts right
they've seen a massive surge in
followers
while democrat accounts have been
shrinking
okay
here's the thing again keep in mind
marley was dead to begin with elon musk
isn't doing anything there right now
it's just the fear that he might at some
point
let me give you the follower differences
between uh the 27th and the 30th uh
that we see okay so
republican followers gained let's go
through jim jordan hundred and sixty
thousand okay margery taylor greene so
150 000 gains ted cruz so 118 000 gained
now let's contrast that with
democrats notable democrats national
figures bernie sanders saw a decrease of
25 000 hillary clinton saw a decrease of
18 000 elizabeth warren saw a decrease
of 16 000 nancy pelosi saw a decrease of
13 000.
allegedly with
hillary clinton though those people may
have committed suicide yes they may have
alcohol
well here's the thing is i want to this
is also something that like look at what
the opposition is saying how are they
arguing now
when conservatives were removed from
twitter right what would you see if they
were actual people these were actual
accounts because some liberals have
tried to say you know what they're
they're they're they're purging liberals
now they're just deleting liberals this
is authoritarianism okay when
conservatives were being removed from
twitter
where they go to facebook they would go
to instagram they would go on youtube
right they would go to parlor they would
go to rumble and let you know hey i've
been suspended you always knew if
someone was removed from twitter if it
was an actual person are you seeing
anyone on the left right now are you
seeing any actual people telling you my
account was suspended i was removed
that's not happening
they would be complaining about it it's
not so you throw that out we know that's
not what's going on right now so what is
most likely happening okay this is a
theory uh they're either purging
accounts that were bots there were fake
accounts because elon musk said he's
going to be really strict on that so of
course they don't want to be
you know brought up on any kind of
business malpractice charges i don't
necessarily know how they would apply
with social media so it's pretty clear
they're either purging bots
non-existent accounts
and with conservatives either banned
accounts are being unbanned falsely
banned accounts or
uh we all know this
because you just saw a gain in like ten
thousand 10 000 this week i saw 50 000
in a day crazy and so many people have
been saying hey i'm seeing you in my
timeline
for the first time in a very long time
people have chosen to follow
my profile and this is the thing with
the algorithms sure someone can follow
you but if someone follows you and
unless they bookmark your page and check
back every day you might as well not
exist which by the way is the reason we
always tell you monday through thursday
10 a.m eastern so you guys if we're not
here on youtube go to rumble or watch us
on mug club monday through thursday 10
a.m eastern just bookmark it and check
back in i'll get to youtube stats in a
second notifications subscriptions don't
necessarily work
so on the left you see purging of
accounts
that weren't real and on the right
you're seeing either unsuspending of
accounts or
just someone like ted cruz his own
people are seeing his stuff so it gets
retweeted it gets put in their timeline
it's to pay it forward that was remember
the whole idea viral well you can't go
viral nothing can go viral if it can't
start
if you have five million people who
follow you but twitter says ah you're
only going to reach 20 000.
the number doesn't matter so that's what
we're seeing now let me let me draw
attention to this because you just saw a
gain with republicans and a loss with
democrats okay
to the tune of millions if you were to
add them all up now princeton university
there's research on this they found that
for every this is a quote for every 10
increase of twitter users in a given
county
right that lowered the vote share of
donald trump by 0.2 percentage points
that's weird that could almost
sway things yes think about that for a
second think about right now they're
saying beto you know they could win in
texas or like he's really close he's
within two percent
okay
well
now let's just say abbott
gains
the followers just based on the natural
algorithm and all of a sudden beta loses
hundreds of thousands you think that
changes the election
so they combine algorithms they combine
throttling they combine fake accounts
and by the way this is a dirty little
secret i cannot substantiate this i want
to be clear but i've worked in this
industry for a very long time you pay
you pay a pr firm you get a set amount
of twitter followers don't ask questions
sort of like you pay a certain amount to
a pr firm you get a new york times best
seller by the way no one really knows
what uh constitutes a new york times
bestseller but you give us a quarter
million dollars we guarantee it don't
ask questions so i'm sure that there are
a lot of democrat pr firms
that have been buying up fake accounts
there are a lot of reasons that has been
this has been taking place
all of it points one direction and again
if people if you could comment below
send me examples are there any prominent
democrats
i haven't seen them saying hey i've been
removed i know they're threatening to
leave and then they come back like sean
king but i haven't seen any stories of
democrats i'm asking i've been removed
from twitter this is what's happening i
see them bitching about it where we saw
conservatives all the time get removed
simply for points of view so i gained uh
myself sean king went and went dark for
a day yes and then he went uh he went
he was always cream he just shut down
his twitter poor choice of words true
yeah he went black he's never gone dark
he's never been black or dark no but he
was cream
yes he's still cream eggshell egg shall
we maybe a nice taupe yeah say this
so i gained 89 000 twitter followers
okay
89 000 the course of whatever two or
three days uh now let me also point this
to you now now imagine this for a second
youtube this is something too so we're
seeing this with twitter i can tell you
there are some things i'll need to keep
in my back pocket
so there's some info that i'll never be
able to give to you until the time is
right but i will share share this with
you because it would be publicly
available if you wanted to search for it
uh for years and uh two main time you've
been working here for years so you saw
this happen for for years we on average
gained uh over a hundred thousand
subscribers on youtube per month we had
some months there were a couple hundred
thousand in a month i think the average
was around 120 000. okay then we were
demonetized with the vox adpocalypse and
like that to the day all of a sudden we
went from 130 000 new subscribers a
month
to
about 20 000. maybe 40 40 000 was the
biggest month some months would be 10
000. now here's the thing that's a b
test could be chance we were remonetized
on youtube
for four or five months before people
complained about it again average 130
000 new subscribers per month
demonetized again so now we have four
examples we have a b a b
went down to 10 20 000 new subscribers a
month you're talking about a
differential of hundreds of thousands in
a month and if you do those estimates if
you look at the algorithms for which
there's been no explanation or no answer
we'd probably be at about 9 to 11
million subscribers a month on youtube
not to mention the things like
notifications working subscriptions
working we have to tell you to bookmark
the page and come back 10 a.m eastern
every day and also let you know about
rumble and about mug club
in case we're not on youtube because we
get removed for a reason that is not
described which by the way please do
that's why we don't make any revenue off
of youtube we keep sponsors pretty
limited go to live with credit.com club
and uh you know it's 69 for students
veterans active military you get the
whole blaze catalog
uh this is something that again i think
people are talking people need to not
focus on ah i lost this i gained that
what does that mean for the state of
democracy remember the russia gate how
long the media just even spoke about
donald trump perhaps you know using a
high-eight camera to observe prostitutes
urinating on formica that was a huge
story of course meanwhile we see the
difference of millions
millions of people being barred from
following their supported elected
officials and having others thrust
before them if you're concerned about
the state of democracy if you think
there's some you know we want trust in
our institutions then you should
absolutely be pushing for transparency
this can affect the state of the country
in addition to the hunter biden story
which we know would have changed the
election hey speaking of sean king uh
yes he might be breaking some news oh no
i don't know what his sources are he
tweeted i'm told this morning that apple
and google will remove twitter from the
app store if it does not moderate and
remove hate speech under elon musk this
isn't a new policy but a commitment
already made amazon web services has the
same commitment so there's that and then
he replied to someone who probably was
trying to call bs and he said spoke to
staff at google and apple who referred
me to the following policies
yeah well by the way first off there are
a couple things that are troubling in
there he spoke to officials at google
and apple well we can never get a return
call we have far more influence and far
more people who care about what we say
than sean king of course they're
selective in answering their calls just
like they're selective and who they
decide to throttle you know what else is
he mentions jeff bezos and amazon being
on board with it hey hey hold on hey man
i talked to alexa yeah yeah
alexa is elon mu is elon musk a [ __ ]
i'm sorry i didn't understand that alexa
is elon musk a [ __ ] it's me sean king
come on i have to use my other voice
it's me sean king oh whiskers his face
recognition software he has to put on
his ginger whip
or put on his
puts on his black wig over his ginger
hair right
that's like it's like a rachel dolezal
who got a perm so she could straighten
it so she can act like she straightened
her curly hair no here's the thing he
just mentioned jeff bezos right and
amazon does anyone see a problem with
is he the second richest guy i don't
know i know elon musk is number one is
jeff bezos number two or is he number
three i guess it depends on well does
anyone see a problem with the number two
richest guy
now implementing a policy that would
hurt the number one richest guy
hey what happened to antitrust what
happened to wanting accountability for
businesses look i want accountability
across the board and by the way if this
is true from sean king again here's an
issue sean king doesn't have the
self-awareness to say oh this could be a
slippery slope sort of couch it for
example i say to you very often i
understand that there there are actual
racist message boards or hate places in
the dark web that you know end up being
the bathroom wall of society and most
people don't want to spend time there
that's not twitter
that won't be twitter simply because you
don't remove someone for saying that
anthony fauci isn't the final voice on
science i understand that they don't
acknowledge what the other side's
concern is because they don't know it
sean king doesn't understand it here's
the here's the real value that
conservatives and that i hope if nothing
else if nothing else beyond the
entertainment if nothing else i've
helped you do is to understand the way
the other side thinks i can tell you
this firsthand
the left doesn't because they don't try
to they cannot even entertain the
possibility that they're wrong they're
an entire group heard
of amber heard that's what the left is
they can never even possibly con
fathom that they would be wrong so now
we look at this hate speech from apple
and amazon okay can we bring up the elon
musk
he was very clear about what he would do
with speech on twitter i believe his
tweet was something to be effective i'm
going by wrote here uh he said you know
speech must follow the law
and twitter will not do anything that
goes beyond the law and that's very
clear so when people say things like oh
free speech you can't you'll fire in a
crowded theater you can't if there's a
fire
you just can't yell fire because it's a
call to action if it's a lie that harms
people
you can tell someone that you hate them
you just can't actually physically hurt
them or call someone else to an action
to harm them because the crime is the
action
not the speech the law is really clear
on it what they want
and they can't even agree on it did you
listen to the phone call from the
twitter board
they're going what are we going to do
what is going to be considered hate
speech like we don't know
so you can't give us an answer but you
want but you're going to ban
one of the top three social media
platforms in the world without even
defining what hate speech is
must be so nice to have no
accountability and to have supporters
sycophants like sean king well that's
all that it is yeah i mean it's all
you look at places here's the problem is
you go to a place where there is
actually the dark web or even places
like reddit that can get real dark or
anything they're not controlled because
they're not big enough to where they can
actually sway anything the reason why
they're so upset about this is because
it does take away their ability to sway
everyone and everything right and to
call people out publicly and and to
actually do throw out misinformation do
things
so insane like prevent the president of
the united states from talking to their
people i don't ever think that joe biden
should be thrown off twitter ever no and
i don't think donald trump should be
thrown off twitter that was absurd no
that's what they're pissed off about is
they can't get they they're no longer
they're
not even at this point yet they're
afraid that they'll no longer be in
charge of the message right and they're
the ones that are pulling out the rug
right now they can't handle that the
least popular of the big three social
platforms facebook i'm using twitter
facebook
instagram and then youtube so facebook
instagram is a subcategory then youtube
is sort of a sub category then you have
uh twitter these are the sort of the big
three
they're concerned that they just won't
have control over the third and think
about it's the same plan of attack that
they had with media right they had abc
nbc cbs then cable came out and they had
cnn and they had cnbc and msnbc and fox
news got
a market share now
why did it work why was it so successful
they got the market share uh for whom
there was nothing available despite
being 789 networks and they would say
they would complain and try and create
laws
to kneecap fox news
it's the same thing that's happening
here well you have facebook you have
instagram you have tik tok along with
the communist chinese party you have
google alphabet you also have youtube
they have independent fact checkers who
by the way are getting their information
straight from the white house seems like
now you have a little bit of spotify
yeah but we want twitter too yeah yeah
but there's fox news if there's if
there's even a chance that people hear
an alternative point of view we're going
to be harmed
just like the new york post story
with hunter biden we know it would have
affected the outcome hey there's been
russiagate there's been donald trump
peeing on prostitutes there's been him
basically you know
shaking hands and having midnight orgies
with putin for all you know with these
articles coming out from the new york
times and washington post false story
after false story after false story
verifiably false they don't have to have
accountability for themselves they don't
so they go it's amazing new york post
needs to be removed well you got
facebook you got yeah but twitter though
and then they all you think it's chance
why do you think apple and amazon
you think it's just chance that they're
if sean king is writing by the way i
don't necessarily i i tend to think it's
a 50 50 shot that he's just making stuff
up but the fake yeah the fake guy who
made a bunch of money off blm right but
he has a quizling and so they will use
him and throw him a bone every now and
then yeah i mean he he does own a boys
in the hood shirt yes he does
but even though to me seems about as
black as a water polo yes
black is actual polo yes
if it's true you think it's just by
happenstance that apple and amazon
the other richest guys out there who are
powerful happen to come together to try
and take down the one rich guy it
doesn't require any inconsistency for me
to say all right elon musk wants to take
over twitter great
i think that there should be section 230
reforms oh okay uh someone else owns
another platform great i think there
should be section 230 reforms
but for them to say hold on a second we
need uh antitrust that's what jinsaki
just said the other day which by the way
has nothing to do with 230 that's the
bait and switch she's at 2 30 looking at
antitrust with these big companies oh
hey annie trust how about apple on
amazon today in agreement to remove
twitter
to harm one of their competitors
huh what about anti-interest it requires
inconsistency from the left it it's not
that it just it's not a product
it's not a symptom
of progressivism
it is a requirement to be a leftist to
abandon the concept of consistency
but you gave but we didn't give elon
musk his billions of dollars no we did
not this is a guy who made it
well they bought his they bought it they
bought his car yeah they are mad that
the guy who made the electric car
drivable it's crazy you created this
scary monster yeah you drive his cars
and then you're mad at them you're like
oh this bastard i got to get in this car
now and drive to work
it makes no sense but you you're angry
at him but you're not angry at the
government who's printing out trillions
of dollars while taking your trillions
of dollars and mismanaging them yeah
you're pissed off about what a guy's
doing with his money right what do you
care right when you look at somebody
like okay bill gates msnbc do you have a
problem with that it's the same thing
right it's another source of information
that's owned by a billionaire pushing
that out to the public jeff bezos
washington post right is that a problem
is that a problem
think about this jeff bezos washington
post one of the most powerful men in the
world had a reporter who was walking
around with daddy's checkbook daddy in
this instance of jeff bezos just to be
clear doxing an anonymous independent
content creator with libs of tick tock
and you guys say you're for the little
guy
while creating the ministry of truth and
i'm slowly stopping i i you know you
eventually had to start using amazon
with the pandemic right you're like i
can't go nowhere right i'll have this
guy come here it's dead right but uh i
i i'm slowly stopping to use them i just
don't want to deal with it anymore i
just don't want to support the company
right yeah and i'm not against people
that work there it's just i don't i
don't like him and i don't like his like
what he's doing well it's also changed
after black lives matter you know you
want to go to brick and mortar stores
but unfortunately it's just
the stores just have bricks windows and
they've been hit with mortar shells yeah
they're pretty much just you just hold
mortars
[Laughter]
if you want to buy this car not really
it's on fire yeah well you know what
fine would you like to buy a 93 door
yeah would you like to buy a 93
oldsmobile you can go over there to the
theater they still sell some it's
basically a used car lot hey speaking of
consistency by the way uh the
consistency of our sponsor here this uh
today good ranchers i've talked about
this yes they saw it here good ranchers
uh american meat delivered one thing a
lot of people don't realize is a lot of
the meat you get in stores not coming
from the united states no china nope a
lot of it so good ranchers actually uh
sources it from ranchers here in the
united states and they deliver it to you
the prices are incredible i got to tell
you i had a ribeye uh three days ago it
was the second best rib i've ever had in
my life
second best i don't think they'll be mad
at me saying this was the one time
someone bought me like this ultra uber
expensive dry whatever ribeye that i've
made at home
that was the only time and it could just
be subjective that i would say that was
the best steak i've ever had but the
prices that good ranches are better than
you often get in the grocery stores
better quality and uh right now they
have a american an american waigu burger
what am i doing with this this is
actually this is ribbon
no i like it more than the burger but
they have individually wrapped burgers
easy to cook you can put them in tacos
meatballs i don't know but if you enter
in the promo code crowder at
goodranchers.com crowder you will
actually get 25 off every delivery for a
lifetime lock that price in right now i
bet you wish you would have locked in
that price before the the price of beef
went up uh i don't know what the last
two weeks
oh and the next two and the two after
that yep buy the market while it's low
and two two three pounds of the american
baguette that's right you get two free
pounds of american wagoo yields good
it's seriously really good you'll die
like john wayne with uh 20 pounds of
compacted red meat and yes
on the toilet with balls full of steak
and coffee
this is one of those rumors i remember
people believe that
it's not possible
uh all right so here speaking of that
you were talking about printing money
this is something i really want to talk
about too is uh the recession all right
that's uh coming up and by the way we're
gonna go by the way i thought we were in
one i know good news there's another one
on the way no no no you're someone
actually feeling the effects you're not
an economist on television i it's just
it's it's the second tax bill i've got
where i'm like wow all of it right i was
driving yesterday and i was talking to
one of my family members and this
actually happened in the middle this
person was talking about something very
serious a health issue that had come up
and i was like yeah no i'm listening
well you know what you got to put it in
god's hands and i just and pardon if you
have kids i just i just well i guess
i'll hit the mute button i was listening
i'm like yeah well look i'm here
and the reason was i saw that gas went
to 399.
so fast it went down for a minute yep
four dollars in texas
i don't even know how that happens mine
takes premium it's almost five again
good lord
so let's go through this okay according
to the consumer price index and i want
to fill you in on this because a lot of
people sort of again talked about the
economy let me let me consolidate it so
you understand why we have never been in
this kind of a scenario ever in the
history of uh america and it not
resulted in a bad recession this isn't
me doing a jim cramer and sell i'm just
telling you
it's never happened before it's been a
100 chance that with all of these
indicators you have a very bad recession
and by very bad i mean get worse than it
is now so according to the consumer
price index inflation rose by about
eight and a half percent year over year
in march that's the biggest increase in
over 40 years so to give you some
some context food is an 8.8 increase
energy 32 increase and i know what some
of you are saying that sounds really low
right food only 8.8 you would take that
as a win that's because these numbers
are actually the result of again
tweaking the methods of measuring
inflation so it seems much lower than
how we've measured it historically don't
take my word for it
people think of us as having had 13 14
percent inflation in the 1970s
but that's only because of the way it
was calculated then
if you use the same way we calculate
inflation now
it got just above 10
in the 1970s
so getting to eight and a half we're
actually closer to being back there than
i think most people realize now do you
notice what he said he said we're closer
to being back there no i say i don't
know if you know this but that was a lie
yes yeah and the reason why is because
if we're using that same sort of 1980
model if it was the same model being
used today inflation would actually be
closer to 17
so he's like we're almost there at the
uh 11 or 14. it's like no no look behind
you that's there
it's seven less
17
and they get away with this there's like
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah no inflation's
only eight and a half wait a second what
about uh well how are you doing that oh
no we used it this way but we're not
doing it that way anymore well in the
70s i wasn't around but through various
documentaries and movies i've seen
people didn't drive anywhere right they
really just stayed at home and cooked
like there was a real problem yeah no
there was a documentary about last week
oh i see so oh you're right i was
watching the news yes yes that's what it
was now regardless and here here are a
few key indicators and like you're
talking about there's a disconnect
between what they're trying to claim on
media and what you're experiencing
regardless of what biden has been saying
real wages are not going up so in 2021
inflation actually outpaced wage gains
by one point you're losing money you're
losing money
it's the it's the greatest tax on lower
and middle class american people is
inflation it's effectively attacks for
you as you experience it your money is
now worth less than the day before
that's a really big problem everybody is
feeling it now let me explain to you the
methods that the left will tell you
would work and exactly why historically
they've worked zero percent of the time
here is former vice president biden's
brilliant plan
one way to fight inflation is to drive
down wages and make americans poor
i think i have a better idea to fight
inflation
lower your cost not your wages
[Applause]
we could have done that
you know yeah that's a good idea you
should uh here's an idea go to a russia
for gas in china yes that's a good idea
oh source it at home lower my costs not
my wages i didn't oh okay so if i'm a
farmer just lower the cost of the raw
materials like fertilizer better yet
i'll just lower the costs of ammonia
here i'll just lower the costs of feed
for the kettle right here i'll just
lower the cost the energy costs of
heating and lighting a studio you know
i've done i've done the math and i have
a bullet for me and every one of my
family members left over you are a
miracle in cost lowering this is great i
should call you dave rollback thank you
what an ass this is the problem though
people listen to this and they go yeah
that makes perfect sense yeah up what do
you think they're just gouging you
this is the problem with this country
people think that if you
franchise a subway you're a
multi-billionaire i think if you you're
a farmer you're right if you own a
business yeah you're automatically a
billionaire you're not yeah most people
struggle for a very long time to own a
company and if you're lucky you come out
on top people uh you know if i do
airport runs i pick them up in my car
they go oh really
yeah that's always a nice feeling
so i just would have expected better i
would have expected better look i'll
tell you this the cost of just because
we we have to get the mugs unfortunately
overseas but we have americans who paint
and etch these mugs the costs have gone
up dramatically we haven't raised the
cost for mug club for people out there
why because we don't want to we know
that you're hurting as well but i will
tell you it's a sting
we have to just cut some costs somewhere
we can't just bring down the cost of
someone else's [ __ ] so that's his plan
okay so barring that genius
uh
10-year
plan should tell hunter to just pay less
for coke yeah i should like no just
shortchange your dealer and see how that
works that's how it started just smoke
the drywall yeah yeah all right that's
fine that's why i went for cheese
so the federal reserve the other thing
they'll have to do is the federal
reserve is going to have to raise
interest rates okay now for people who
don't understand this you hear this a
lot right i don't know if you when i say
the fed reserve raises interest rates
yes you might have some questions what
well i yeah i get it okay some people
out there and this is not because you're
ignorant but a lot of you are an
economist it basically means the rate at
which commercial banks borrow and lend
right from the reserves this is what
we're talking about with the federal
reserve okay because some people will
say well if they raise interest rates
that's not my rate well no we're not
talking about your rate necessarily with
the bank that's what we're talking about
the rate you have locked in is not going
to be it's going to be yours right so
that's exactly what this government
plans to do they're going to raise the
interest rate for new buyers to 2.75
for now by the end of next year
let me give you out what they would
argue again all references available at
square.com in theory it's simple the fed
raises interest rates right that
decreases demand and inflation falls
that's never happened
as
the wall street journal points out and
believe me i'm very careful to couch my
words like it usually doesn't
because someone can find one example
hey ask me if any like point to any
example well let's see no there you go
so the wall street journal
you don't remember
you can get a house for basically free
with a five percent interest rate
that happened
so
boy so you mean you're still paying sh
look for your home so the wall street
journal uh pointed out uh this that uh
this is a quote from office journal the
federal reserve is setting out to do
something it has never accomplished
before reduce inflation a lot without
significantly raising unemployment now
the goal is to lower inflation by four
percent okay they've never done that
again ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
without causing a recession now rapidly
increasing interest rates that is
horrible for economic growth take it
from someone who isn't conservative and
not me
what you have is an um
enough tightening
by the federal reserve means raising
rates to deal with inflation adequately
there's too much tightening for the
markets and uh the economy so the fed is
going to be in a very difficult place a
year from now as inflation still remains
high and it starts to pinch on both the
markets and the economy right so what
they're trying to get here is what they
call a soft landing yeah they use terms
like tightening
yes
raising rates because if you're
tightening you're like oh they're gonna
tighten they're gonna become more
fiscally responsible no no no no there's
no borrowing and printing money the term
tightening it's almost the opposite of
that well it means you have to tighten
your pockets if you want to survive yes
that's what tightening means exactly
yeah well the fad lives high in the hog
we will survive i would rather go back
into the jail and take my turns with men
it will be extremely painful
for me
have you been to kroger that man was
right so uh they want a soft landing
they want to try and curb demand and
they want there to be no layoffs and
they want to try and decrease inflation
and they want to avoid a recession
here's the thing trying to make all of
those things work by raising the
interest rates it's an incredibly
unlikely scenario by unlikely i mean
it's never happened before listen to
someone say it again and then i'll
explain why so is the soft landing
just pie in the sky stuff
um
when you say soft landing i i i i i i
there's no going to be yeah i don't it's
pie in the sky stuff um i think that
most likely what we're have going to
have is a period of stagflation
which is a software and then you have to
understand how to build a portfolio
that's balanced
um for that kind of an environment the
stagflation rises here's
the thing for people who don't know what
stagflation means it's basically a
scenario we have high inflation in a
shrinking economy high unemployment okay
just to be clear so they use these terms
tightening soft landing stagflation and
when i was learning about this i was
about 16 years old when i started taking
an interest i would fake like i knew
like oh yeah stagflation then go go back
and read it and go okay oh now i
understand for the next conversation so
hopefully this helps you you're not
stupid if you don't know all these terms
it's designed to obfuscate i'm trying to
simplify it as much as my as much as i
can so that you can understand it their
goal is to ensure that you don't
understand it it's throwing off a guy
who's an expert in this right yeah you
shouldn't know all of it that's the goal
and the reason why is because they want
you to trust the authority figures they
don't want you to have access to the
signs from reporters
like all of us they want you to trust
the science fauchi they don't want you
to really know
if they just say well we're talking
about a scenario with high inflation in
a shrinking economy high unemployment
that sucks like we'll just call it
stagnation
what it's not as bad or just call it a
soft landing they want you to not be
able to understand this so that you have
to trust an authority figure like the
ministry of truth as it relates to
disinformation online my goal is to try
and make this as simple as possible
that's reductive dear god i hope so so
the fed has tried this many times before
let me give you some historical examples
okay 1950s they tried to do this you saw
inflation spikes you saw recessions
1970s inflation fell then it surged
higher due to outside factors like you
had the oil shock i don't think many
people would argue the 1970s was
a booming economy that the american
public was proud of yeah the early 1980s
were fed the fed pushed the interest
rates to 20
recession double digit unemployment now
you do have 1994 alan greenspan raised
the rates from three to six percent and
unemployment stayed down here's the
thing in that case the fed was ahead of
inflation
right now they're behind it
so if someone says well what about the
allen greenspan their name you haven't
heard in a while uh
there's a difference between being a
head of inflation and trying to catch up
with something it's like imagine right a
car in front of you versus a car behind
you
it's just you in a car you have the same
pieces you have the same elements but a
very very different scenario one is
something you'll never catch one is
going to murder you
true yeah
so it makes common sense
so this is according to a stanford
economist john taylor he wrote this this
is not the only time in history that
they've been behind but they are
strikingly behind now there are a few
things that are going to make this even
harder and worse because you're saying
well maybe this will be the first time
well they'll get it right yeah because
it's not like there's a litany of
confounding outside factors right now
that would take this entire stew or
gumbo of fuckupedness and make it worse
like russia's invasion of the ukraine
which reduced the oil supply worldwide
leading to higher oil prices right you
have a 13-year high
higher gas prices more expensive
shipping you have a second shock shock
coming to the economy when you have all
these these western uh you know refiners
you're talking about these these
european nations they're now walking
away from from russian oil and it's not
just russian oil that's compounded by
the fact that we have an administration
who's made it very clear that they don't
want us to be energy independent because
they want to move us to what renewable
energy and things like electric cars but
oh [ __ ] elon musk owns twitter what are
they going to do there's no place for
them to go without being raped by their
own life's previous mistakes and it is
wonderful it would be if it weren't
negatively affecting you you think this
guy who right now is on cnn former vice
president biden you think he's going to
be stung
you think he's going to feel it
sending more money to ukraine great
great wonderful perfect 33 billion to
ukraine oh fantastic well you don't like
ukrainians uh it's not that though most
that i've met have kind of been surly
it's that i think we have people in the
united states who could probably use
that money or hey how about this just
let us keep it
well you keep i hate that the argument
is that you uh elon musk could do how
much with this many billion that he
spent on twitter that's your money
[Laughter]
you told people to buy an electric car
then they did and by the way
he made the electric car more affordable
yes he has the tesla three well you get
it for 30 something thousand dollars
yeah they're cheap yeah they're not that
expensive now for a car now that's great
well they're all over prices yeah
they're all over here it's insane but
yeah that's also his fault
yeah
so it's just amazing see inflation makes
things higher yes exactly that's how
that works uh the only way by the way
for the demand for oil would go down
is if there's a recession so now we
combine that with again are we in a
better scenario than in the past where
maybe this would be the exception well
we have lockdowns in china remember
china yeah 20 of the world's 90 000
container ships are currently stuck off
port 30
of all of that is in china
just to be clear remember it's the red
right there yeah that's the red one is
that was that a graph that came up yeah
what i saw yeah
that's exciting
so we have these restraints on supply
shines uh supply chains supply chains in
china
it impacts all kinds of industries like
electronics home appliances textiles
everything everything and here's the
thing when there's when there's a low
supply and you have this overheated
demand
that's again when you end up with
inflation also something to take into
account keep in mind you gave people
money during a pandemic you locked it
down and you gave them money for
products that didn't exist because the
shelves were empty so they're sitting
there with money guess what that does
that also ends up leading
to a disruption of the supply chain to a
disruption
of the value of the dollar
anyway
oh we have a clip okay the shanghai
lockdowns right now they're not getting
any better of course because uh
right now in shanghai you may not know
this because so there's still just
people starving to death well they're
literally being fenced in in shanghai
right now this is unbelievable
come out and get your test
yeah
we heard the faucet pandemic is over
shut your mouth shaky speak otherwise
where is the dog
with the megaphone duct taped
this is terrifying
and keep that in mind every time you see
i don't know like a red dawn where we
have to remove the chinese flags and
replace them with north korean flags or
every time john cena comes out and asks
to apologize to the government of china
because they don't want to offend them
the people
who they are appeasing are the
government officials
doing that to their citizens
so don't accuse me of racism or anyone
here of racism because we hate the
communist chinese party because we hate
what they're doing to those chinese
people and you're not doing [ __ ] you're
cow towing
now there are fears of lockdown
spreading to where beijing that's going
to hit global markets too you've already
seen it happen with shipping you've
already seen what we've already gone
through that you can hear all right
there's a huge market if that hits that
yeah it's a huge terrifying yeah john
cena's gonna be out of a job yeah i mean
how many times can you pretend the
countries don't exist i don't know i
mean it's like i mean you can make it
your thing you know like senior when
says like sorry no [ __ ] there's no
taiwanese all right no taiwan
hey do it like we rehearse these are
good people
oh just showing up to make a wishes
before i come in
do you think that this country exists
yes
and none of these children are taiwanese
correct is that i just wanna make sure
no oh there's one he's gonna need to
leave before i shake hands could i just
uh pull the chemo from us uh can we just
how quickly can we get him out of the
way i accidentally flipped one of the
beds
and i'm all natural
yeah so that's why i'm 50 and look like
this yeah and my forehead has grown
eighteen sizes i have to get baseball
caps custom
what steroids are you taking
frankenberry yes
so um you combine the international
effects and now let's go with the us us
government spending again this recession
it's
these factors have never added up to
anything other than [ __ ]
so united states has borrowed they spent
uh 6.4 trillion
since covid
hit now in 2021 for context world war ii
cost us 4.1 trillion so 6.4 trillion
and just in the dollars versus world war
ii 4.1 trillion and that actually
affected the entire world yes yeah i
mean we dropped we dropped the bomb
we beat hitler yeah yeah and finally
finally those jabs had to pay right nazi
we're sure we're a useless society
how does that mean in the world not just
america not america let's say you really
do you think covet is this pandemic and
you hate it look do you really think
that this government actually believes
when you look at what we know about
kovid that it was more harmful to
humanity at large
then hitler and the axis of evil that's
a pretty tough argument to make comment
below if you want to make it
change my mind well they're using the
same disease tactics depending on what
part of the world you're in yeah i guess
i have no idea
i don't know what diseases they had but
they were such a disease well hitler
lied about them having diseases that's
true kind of like the chinese government
is
lying about yeah no let's not know we
love china no china's the best yeah
taiwan's not a thing so here we also go
back to what happened during we shut
down the country at the government
stimulus right they also played a huge
part in ruining the job market okay uh
gave people money to not work so what
happened still are right they still uh
they still are yeah in some cases they
still are so in february there were 11
point something million job openings
what do we have eleven point three okay
uh that's four million more job openings
and pre-pandemics so will they try and
tell you we're bouncing back we're not
that's what we would call in this
industry it's you know uh entertainment
industry nomenclature a lie
so there's four million more available
jobs than pre pandemic so what happens
look this is very simple you can either
just believe joe biden who says hey
businesses lower your costs or
understand that companies that need
workers have to increase wages remember
they used to fight for 15 remember that
was a thing now they're fighting for 25
because 15 is a starting job
15 is a starting job right up the street
at dunkin donuts
you become a shift manager within like
three weeks
and you make 17.50 an hour and i was
saying that's not enough well you know
what here's the thing for once the
unions are accidentally correct because
of the inflation due to the politicians
who you give 99 of your dues
to elect so companies need more workers
what happens they have to increase wages
and what happens the prices go up in
march the united states participation
rate for the labor force was 64.2 that's
lower than pre pre-pandemic
we have more job openings than
pre-pandemic and we have fewer people
even trying to participate in the job
market than pre-pandemic we have crazy
inflation that we did not have
pre-pandemic we have crazy gas prices
that we did not have pre-pandemic now
what happens biden says that he wants to
forgive what solution more than 1.5
trillion in student loans so that sounds
nice because people go that means i have
to pay less i like paying less for
things vote here's the problem where do
we get it borrow more money or print
more money i don't know if you know this
if you have 10 of something as opposed
to one
10 makes it less valuable
just think of baseball cards or
superhero cards when you were a kid it's
never happened that the fed prints more
money
without inflation following and by the
way it would be impossible it'd be
impossible absolutely impossible unless
you just lower your cost well sure it's
lower your costs
stop you complaining
well if you make two of something and
you have it you've lowered the value of
one yeah i know that when i you know
when i
cook a whole tray of the nestle toll
house cookies yeah i should appreciate i
should savor each bite but at that point
i don't because i know i have another
one no you're throwing out some of them
yeah yeah some of them go bad you don't
even care at some point i just rub them
all over myself that's nonsense
you've seen scrooge mcduck with all the
money he swims in it yes you do with
cookies i've been i've bend your cookie
vault why because i can't i've broken
into your cookie though yeah i know i
know i just see it i just see a dave
shaped hole yeah you'd be surprised
landing on cookies it is softer than
coins but still immensely painful it's a
it's a soft landing it is it's a very
soft landing yeah it's a pie there's
chocolate chip flaking it's a cookie in
the sky landing yes very messy
so um what a delicious mess here's the
thing it's not just right wing
economists who are concerned about this
coming and this is why you don't really
see it this is why they want to talk
about ukraine this is why they don't
want to talk about covet they don't
really want to talk about twitter they
want to operate behind the scenes in the
darkness right so they don't really want
to talk about the economy because even
their own people acknowledge what i've
just told you here's former clinton
treasury uh secretary larry summers
sounding the alarm lori there was a bank
of america survey of fund managers out
this week and the big headline was
concerns about stagflation it's higher
than it's been since certainly 2008 or
so uh how concerned should we be about
stagflation you mispronounced whatever
the most likely place we're going to be
if stagflation means
rising unemployment and still high
inflation
i think that's the preponderant
probability as to what he's asking if
stagflation means that
right you tell us a couple of years
over the next couple of years as i've
said before on your show no one can do
anything but dance around a questionful
fact that needs to inform our view
is that we've never had a moment when
unemployment was below four inflation
was above four and we avoided recession
for the next two subsequent two years
and right now unemployment's well below
four
and inflation is well above four lots of
people say look the job market is so
strong why would anyone think we're
going to have no one's saying that what
no one's saying that for me is that the
lower unemployment is the more likely it
is that it's going to uh turn down in
subsequent months all right look
but that guy just said his [ __ ] let
me give you a wrap up okay just so we
can let's let's go through the sequence
of events all right shut down the
economy destroy the world spend more
money than we actually spent during
world war ii yeah okay do that then we
punish businesses we force them to stay
closed we give people money to stay home
then we make sure that we are no longer
energy independent or we ensure that we
won't be energy independent in the
future and then we have
extemporaneous uh extraneous factors
here like china we have russia we have
ukraine which skyrockets the prices of
oil right so gas energy and instead the
solution that we see coming from this
administration is hey just reduce your
costs of goods so what happens people
are paid to stay home and not work
businesses now that have if they're
lucky enough to still be a lot still be
open have to pay more for the same
product and pass that cost onto
consumers again more inflation then we
borrow more money than ever in the
history of the united states and print
more money than ever in the history of
the united states which we know leads to
more inflation and now in this case what
we just want to do to solve it is spend
more money and raise interest rates
which again have caused more inflation
but the good news is they're spending
more time on ensuring that your your
six-year-old can transition from chat to
sparkle so they have their priorities
straight they're also making sure that
you know misinformation online isn't
getting out there and they're making
sure that they communicate with the
folks at spotify and apple and amazon to
ensure that elon musk the guy whose cars
they just told you to buy due to their
skyrocketing energy prices and uh
all-time high gas prices by the way to
make sure that their guys now hurt their
competition in elon musk on twitter
because god forbid you actually have
access to free information look let me
ask you this you see all these things
happening look at each individual step
all references available a lot of
care.com
how are any of them justified as
doing it for you
the only one that someone can make an
argument is the 1.5 trillion in student
loan forgiveness if you're a selfish
prick but outside of that it's pretty
hard to even argue that these were done
to help you the working american or the
small business owner never it's been
designed to help them and you are
dealing with the consequences we have
never had a similar scenario i'm leaving
you with this we have never had a
similar scenario taken these same steps
and ended up with anything other than
the american taxpayer and that's all
american taxpayers not just the poor not
just the middle class not just the rest
all american taxpayers being screwed
period an exception no no exceptions
we're going to take some chat and
there's also an inter-office fight here
over a wheelchair which is going to get
heated and we can't talk about on
youtube so youtube uh
we're going to mug club you better piss
off